it used to be a useful term it
identified a very tiny number of people
and the way that you could tell that
they were white supremacists is that if
you asked them they were they'd say hell
yeah feel superior and are very proud of
of the fact that they're they're white
and better than you so we've lost that
term hello and welcome to trigonometry
I'm Francis Foster I'm Constance in
kisum and this is a show for you if
you're bored with people arguing on the
internet over subjects they know nothing
about and trigonometry we don't pretend
to be the experts we ask the experts
our brilliant guest this week is a
journalist and an award-winning novelist
Lionel Shriver welcome to trigonometry
Thanks nice to be here it's so good to
have you here well let's before we dive
into things just tell most people will
know exactly who you are before anyone
who doesn't tell everybody who are you
what's your story how what's your
journey through life and how are you
here today how long as you got exactly
an hour I'm primarily a novelist
although I have done increasing amounts
of mostly opinion journalism some
features in the last several years
currently have a column and standpoint
and in harbors magazine in the US you
can tell by my accent that I'm American
but I have been in the UK over 30 years
so I've really protected that accent I'm
probably best known for my seventh novel
We Need to Talk About Kevin but I have
published several since then I guess I
am currently at 13 books my most recent
book was a collection of short stories
and novellas called property and the
novel before that was the mandibles a
family 20 29 to 20 47 and that's about
economic apocalypse in the United States
and then in your future well one of the
things you've been writing extensively
about and I imagine it might be a
frustration for you given how
accomplished your eyes and novelists
that the interviews often end up being
about the journalists I'm a thing a
journalistic side of things but an issue
that as you know I we've encountered on
the show and I've personally encountered
is free speech and censorious on student
campuses and so on and it's a
conversation that's ongoing and one of
the things I wanted to ask you about
we're trying to work it out for
ourselves is one of the arguments that
often gets made on the progressive side
is that freeze we have free speech
you're free to say what you want and if
other people take issue with that and
mob you on Twitter or get you fired well
those are the consequences of your
freedom of speech and that's all fine
what do you make of that argument well
you you cut the the problem in in a
nutshell if what you says say gets you
fired then you're that's not free speech
and that's why we're encountering so
much self-censorship right now because I
think that identity politics has brought
in a very fearful
cultural environment so we don't know
how much people in my profession for
example are not writing things because
there's no record of what you don't do
right there's no record of what you
think but don't allow yourself to say
and I resist the whole climate I resist
the idea that there are a set of
opinions which everyone must subscribe
to in any tiny departure from that any
use of language that the
isn't following these very strict rules
is is going to get you in terrible
trouble so you don't get sin it's
unhealthy now we talk about especially
in comedy comedy the comedy industry is
one giant ultra liberal bubble and they
acquit are they if they would say first
of all there's no issue with free speech
how can there be and you can say what
you like how you like when you like and
they also say that free speech as well
is a is a right-wing issue it's just for
people on the fringes who want to show
the racial epithets where do you stand
on that I think the fact that free
speech has shifted from the left to the
right is a catastrophe in truth it is it
is it doesn't belong to either side of
it's something that belongs to all of us
and if if the right loses the the right
to say what it wishes then that's a loss
for the left as well because sooner or
later that kind of restriction is is
going to hit you and I think that's one
of the biggest mistakes that that the
Millennial Left tends to make is they
think they're always going to be in a
position of calling the shots and making
the rules and so because they're so
right on because they're so woke you
know that that a client that could
climate of fear that I'm talking about
that that is restrictive it does keep
people from saying things it does
restrict freedom of speech that's not
going to affect them because they they
had the right opinions so that when they
voice the right opinions then they're
never going to get into trouble and
they're never going to lose their jobs
and they're never gonna suffer from a
pile-on in twitter that gives them a
nervous breakdown right because they're
good people right but it's a it's a huge
mistake
it's like young people always thinking
that they're going to be young forever
right which all young people did
[Laughter]
ruin your day but eventually someone
else sets the rules and if you have not
allowed a cultural latitude for
expressing something that is not a
departs from the orthodoxy of the day
then then you know your restrictive
environment is going to bite you and
your own bum and and therefore it isn't
a left or right wing issue and this
whole idea that that the only reason
people keep nattering on about free
speech is that they just want to use
racist language and promote bigotry well
it it's a bigotry and it's an ignorance
and what do you think it comes from this
this desire to be censorious desire to
shut down opinions that you feel
uncomfortable listening to do you think
it comes from from a position of
intolerance what you think it's a
misguided sense of good and trying to
fake you know eliminate people who have
got unpleasant views as it were well it
feels good to tell people what to do no
I I believe that a lot of the people who
are the self-appointed enforcers of what
we are and are not allowed to say they
think they're they're motivated by
virtue they do
but I think the thrill of it isn't the
thrill of doing good I think the thrill
of it is authoritarian that you're
pushing other people around you're
punishing them when they get out of line
it's it's all about power and you think
the narcissism plays a certain aspect of
it that's for instance with the Roger
Scruton affair when George Eaton got
essentially helped to get Roger Scruton
5 he put a post on instagram with
himself swinging a bottle of champagne
saying that I'm quoted on this probably
quite a but essentially said that
feeling you get when you get a racist
sect
yeah well I mean that's a good example
he'd bagged a trophy this is it's a this
is actually a predatory sport and
getting people sacked it is now one of
the things that you do on social media
and and even now because that was the
New Statesman in mainstream media I
thought that was especially unseemly I
it it did it it surprised me that that
happened at the New Statesman it's
interesting you say I've been what
Francis says because I know that I like
computer games sometimes and that
feeling where you have the ability to
type something into your own little
computer and a human being on the other
end of that communication does something
different or something happens you know
you get even on this platform twitch
which is where you watch other people
play computer games I said there's a
platform that exists how I know I guess
that means that that for the that
audience the paint has already dried and
so one of the things that happens and
you're not gonna believe this is they
find out where that person lives who's
streaming this game themselves and they
get a SWAT team they complain about them
saying there's some kind of terrorist
activity happening in that that address
and they get a SWAT team to come in and
knock the door down and arrest them or
take them into custody while it's
happening there is that level of oh if I
do this here then that thing happens
over there and do you think that that is
what's happening with these twitch
twitch fork mobs the Twitter mobs where
essentially it's about power it's about
totally about power in the exercise of
power and one thinks but it's
interesting in the young adult fiction
area which has gone particularly the
nuts like I don't I don't I don't
understand why but
a number of the the writers on some of
these platforms who have been the most
vociferous the most censorious the the
most predatory have also been converted
to pray when they published their own
work and and you know they've got a
character who is gay and they're not gay
or something like that and and then they
end up suffering from the the same mass
attack that they had been organizing
against other people there's a certain
rough justice in that there are some
people particularly people who are
against that kind of ideology who rubbed
their hands and glee at this and go well
look at the left is eating itself and
whatever and and I thought worries me
because I think in a way we're all
eating ourselves when that happens you
know I mean I don't think it's healthy
when I don't think is helping when that
happens to anyone no it is I mean I say
there that there are some rough justice
in that but it we it would be better if
we were not living in a world that this
was happening at all and I'm concerned
that this whole pile on mentality is
infecting major institutions it's
possible I'll write my column about this
this coming weekend but the best example
I can think of is so what happened this
week at Harvard where one of the
professors at the Law School
very distinguished I think he's a Dean
was part of the team who represented
Harvey Weinstein and the students got up
in arms and the administration back down
and and sacked him and this is
completely contrary to the principles of
law I mean this should have been a what
do they call it a teaching moment it's
like sorry but no matter how perfidious
a character may be everyone is deserving
of legal representation
and just because you represent someone
legally that doesn't you know what they
did is not supposed to rub rub off on
you you know that there's a just because
you represent someone you're not
responsible for what they did or didn't
do that's the way the legal system works
and yet just a bunch of students saying
they were uncomfortable or and felt
unsafe and I'm just all this nonsense
all this but early in its insincere crap
and we could get to that in a moment
Harvard caved Harvard Harvard so the
worry is not so much social media you
know if it's contained to Twitter etc
it's painful it's gross it's impolite
and it's cutthroat but the implications
are limited they're no longer limited
where we are now in a mob rule universe
and across the board mainstream
institutions are caving to the pressure
of the crowd and and throwing principal
out the window the same thing is
starting to happen
in in publishing and that's where we
should really be concerned every once in
a while someone and you know in in
publishing or academia and will draw the
line but that's not the forum that's the
exception and how is it affecting the
world of publishing in your own
experience I think it's making
publishers very nervous there was a case
very recently of a book about Israel
that was cancelled
because of again more mob hysteria that
that then it it got something wrong in a
very Pro Palestinian social media
universe and that's you know that's
starting to happen more and more I'm I'm
interested that the the term cancel
culture has entered the vocabulary
that's concerning because when you have
it when you need a name for it then it's
happening in more than was your point
about institutions I think is a really
important one we were just at a
conference on freedom and academic
research and there was probably 20 or so
prominent academics there we talked to
Douglas Murray there we interviewed him
there and just the people went around
the room and it was 10 or 15 people who
detailed their own experience of being
fired on no platform to losing something
because of this and so they know you say
Twitter and I take your point about if
you if it's just contained to Twitter
then that's one thing but I think what
would you say the society we're living
now is the Twitter mob has power or the
student mob has power why do you think
cuz you've written about this Union and
talked about how your generation growing
up you also did some of these things
protesting about stuff and whatever but
how do we how did we get to a point
where we don't go oh these are just
silly students doing their thing they
need to rebel against something how do
we get to a point where went from that
to these students are protesting and we
must take action it's a little
mystifying but it is it has something to
do with Commerce
I mean academia has gone through
transformation to regard itself more as
a business and therefore the customers
are are saying you know we don't like
your product so we need to change the
product it's a it's a I think it's a an
unfortunate way of thinking about higher
education but it's
it changes behavior I also get the
impression from people I've spoken to
who work at universities that the the
people who exercise the most power now
is the administration and not faculty
there's been a reduction in tenure but
something that there must have been some
reorganization as well it's it's it's
worse than just not having enough
tenured professors but they don't call
the shots anymore and administrators are
bureaucrats and bureaucrats are famously
cowardly so it's the bureaucrats who are
making these decisions and that's and
it's the bureaucrats who have been
instrumental in turning turning these
you know often story culturally vital
institutions into a kind into Walmart
and so as far as they're concerned you
know if they're there enough of the
customers are upset then then you remove
the product from the shelves and you
think the fact that we've introduced
tuition fees and now it's 9,000 pounds a
year in the UK to go to university here
do you think that makes it worse now now
that the fact you know that you're
paying you know 27,000 purely in tuition
for using you've got your accommodation
books on top people now feel that they
have a right to go if I don't agree with
this I can now get rid of it
the money here may have something to do
with it though the 9,000 pounds a year
is so Dorst by what you pay for
pot private college education it's
hilarious
it's like spare change and I suspect
that what's going on in UK universities
is less financial and more having in
inherited a cultural backwash from
academia in the United States we do get
a lot from you guys know
yeah you don't look so excited well you
know I'm I'm cool about the movies I
even like you know it when Breaking Bad
comes over here all that's great but the
inheritance from the u.s. is a little
too indiscriminate this is a an
unfortunate contagion and I have found
it mystifying frankly why this academic
culture has spread throughout the West I
mean it's even weirder in Canada and
it's it's it's lunatic in Australia um
there's something odd going on in the
Commonwealth even there's a goofball
contingent in Ireland it seems to have
spread everywhere and it says if the the
world of higher education lives in a all
together in its own bubble and has gone
insane together in spite of the fact
physically there are there all over the
planet how that works I don't get it I
mean maybe they go to a lot of
conferences but it seems quite
puritanical in nature as well recently
I've got a complaint against myself at
the comedy club I'm out but uh for a
joke I mean it's a flattened American I
make a joke about LA when I was 18 I
tried to get in touch with my Latino
roots and that's just a long way of
saying I used to do cocaine
and somebody emailed in and said as in
Latin American woman I find that
offensive especially from a man in power
it's just amazing her attitude was I
don't like it
we should get that's right you know and
this is the kind of you know you talked
it we began the discussion about freedom
of speech and of course we all have
freedom of speech so what
the problem this is a good example now
it's true that the police didn't knock
it down your door and and didn't throw
you in a Cell and put duct tape over
your mouth but you know she felt she had
the right to tell you you couldn't make
that joke and maybe you will think twice
the next day and you just did it again
we're all rebels in this room but I do
take your point sorry to interrupt I do
take your point though I mean I'm just
bloody-minded by nature but somebody who
has got you know more of a career and
they've got a mortgage they would then
feel is it to go and you know keep you
know investigating this particular point
or whatever else well I know that it's a
big problem for professional comedians
I mean it's becoming illegal to be funny
and that's how also a problem for me
because my novels and even my columns
tend to be quite irreverent and and
there's certain kinds of jokes that
you're we are being repeatedly informed
you may not make anymore one of the
things I find really interesting is that
as both of us are working comedians is
you often you go on stage and you do a
joke that you've you've worked out very
carefully and you know that you're not
punching down at any oppressed group or
anything else for example I have a whole
routine about why we need the special
olympics for white people right and it's
making fun of the fact that white people
are not very good at certain things
right so I'm punching up at the white
people in this whole woek we're thinking
but the moment you start talking about
that people get super tense nearly do
even without which it makes it harder to
get them to laugh yeah yeah even though
the target of that joke isn't an
oppressed group but they just hear the
words race or something like that and
automatically everyone tenses up and
this is where I think what you're
talking about this whole culture that is
not necessarily yet reflected in law
although it's getting
I mean I know you've talked about
transgender issues a lot there are
people have been arrested from
misgendering someone on Twitter yeah and
the hate crime
yeah it's a hate crime so a pronoun the
pronouns and but you see I'm so trying
to work it out for myself because the
argument that I put to you right at the
beginning is the argument that I hear
back when I talk about free speech which
is but it's still not illegal you see
you can still go into your jokes you can
still go and perform right and if people
don't like it well it's your problem and
I don't really know necessarily what to
say back to that do you well it it is
often on the way to being illegal I mean
that whole program thing I don't I don't
think the test of censorship is
necessarily law however if socially and
professionally
you cannot allow something to escape
your lips that's not free speech I mean
we're not going to get into what what
the limits of free speech ought to be
necessarily but I think there should be
very few what do you think you need and
I think that the well incitement by to
violence oh that's where I draw the line
but otherwise I'm perfectly happy for
people to say all the ugly bigoted
stupid things they want and then we can
say back that that they're ugly bigoted
and stupid I rather than tell people
that they simply can't say them so i'm i
yeah i end to be on the extreme end and
i'm very hostile to the evolution of
hate crime and hate speech i just talk
about slippery slope what does her
speech mean to you because you put it in
invert
in that the definition of hate speech is
continually changing it's anything that
can be construed as hostile to some
protected group and I think the whole
idea of having legally protected groups
is is off the beam I just I grew up with
the understanding that equality under
the law is one of the principles that
the absolute bedrock principles of
democracy and that where the law the law
applies equally to all of us and all
this specially protected groups means no
it doesn't no it doesn't and we keep
multiplying the specially protected
groups which is why they're fighting
over the meaning of Islamophobia so
suddenly we were going to have one
religion among all religions only one
religion is going to be specially
protected and there's no end to this you
know it potentially just keeps
multiplying it is legally speaking an
evil concept to have hate speech be
against the law and especially now that
the whole um the whole area of hate
speech and hate crime they're defined by
by the victim the only thing that makes
something hate crime is that I said it
was you know you looked at me funny and
I think it was because I was a woman so
that's a hate crime no and you can be
arrested honestly that's the way it gets
recorded that's all that's required is
is is that I decide or you decide that
you're the victim of a hate crime and
then there's a hate crime now that's
utterly absurd and what I find as well
is that how people you know take
snippets from conversations which we saw
with the Roger Scruton affair and then
it's out of context that is seen as
they're being racist Nixon's whatever
else you know like what you just said to
me that could be taken out of context
here's a classic example being being
sexist get rid of it mm-hmm yeah yeah I
mean oh that happened to me about a year
ago with a column I did for The
Spectator and it was one line taken out
of context and spectator has a paywall
not that most of these people would
bother to look up there the larger
column anyway so and then it spread like
wildfire and suddenly Lionel Schreiber's
are a racist although that label is it's
so tired whenever I hear it now I just
laugh um it's interesting to watch how
that word has completely lost its punch
I think that's one of the reasons that
we now call everyone a white supremacist
because racist doesn't mean anything
anymore
well I don't think white supremacist
means anything no no it used to mean
something okay as soon as we started
calling everyone and what white
supremacist then there's no such thing
as a white supremacist anymore it used
to be a useful term it identified a very
tiny number of people and the way that
you could tell that they were white
supremacists is that if you ask them
they were they'd say hell yeah feel
superior and are very proud of of the
fact that they're they're white and
better than you so we've lost that term
that's interesting it's such a good
point this is the thing that worries me
most about this concept creep is that
there are white supremacists there are
white supremacists
there are people who are racist there
are neo-nazis mm-hm and we have to know
who they are and and and now now the
neo-nazis are just Briggs it tears oh
well I'm Annie I'm a Nazi when I turned
on my contract from Sohus the mental
comedian went on the radio and called me
all right and said I'm a nothing I mean
I'm Jewish you're a self-hating and the
thing is with it look my
great-grandfather died fighting the
Germans in World War two right I wonder
how he would feel about my
transformation into a Nazi in context
probably I mean we're living in a world
of ever escalating denunciation and what
that means is that the vocabulary goes
to [ __ ] because nothing means anything
anymore
the the language becomes impoverished
and none of these words mean anything
anymore I've seen it before because I
went for 12 years in Belfast and they
were you know for decades accustomed to
the language of denunciation because
every time there was an atrocity every
time a bomb went off every time someone
was assassinated then the all the
politicians competed with one another
about who could be more disgusted and
and who could deplore the depravity of
these animals more and it was hilarious
to watch the language
just go into contortions I mean the
they're there they're the sources most
you know leafy and fat because
eventually you run out and eventually of
course all those denunciations were
completely meaningless it could have
been passed the salt and the same thing
is is happening now and in some ways
because I don't have need for these
terms myself very much I don't mind I
don't mind it getting all worn out
because I'm tired of this culture of
denunciation and and I'm tired of the
super sensitivity around race and it's
kind of I'm it's kind of amusing to
watch the word racist turn turn into I
don't like you
[Laughter]
the one thing that I find particularly
worried about worrying about this is
that it gives the far-right some
legitimate arguments ago three speeches
on the front here's an example here's
another example here's another example
you've got you've got the lift that
you're not going to stand up for you
who's gonna stand up for you I will yeah
I'm serious
yeah because I'm not on the right and
you know one of the reasons I've written
more journals am I not a natural alterus
and I'm not an actual natural activist
but honestly somebody's got to talk
sense from a liberal perspective and
there are you know there are any number
of people who are doing it and they
garner huge audiences and I you've
interviewed some of them already and and
they're not all super famous
but people like Brendan O'Neill or Ella
Whelan you know very encouraging
examples both of them because they're
young you know and they're thinking for
themselves and their liberally minded
there's a huge hunger not just from the
right but from the center and the center
left for people talking about the
importance of free speech for everyone
for standing up to bullies who are
trying to silence people on campus for
trying to keep the the larger the the
public square of discourse large enough
for everyone to speak their mind and you
know if you go on YouTube some of these
people garner huge huge audiences so
there's there's an appetite out there
and in some ways I guess I've become the
poster girl
for fiction writers because they've been
notably silent you know and I find that
peculiar because we depend on free
speech occupational and you know instead
I hear any number of fiction writers
trying to restrict themselves you know
to support this idea that you know you
have to stay in your lane and and not
write about characters who are different
from you or have a different race or a
different sexual inclination or
something why would you do that to
yourself which like it's like walking
into your study and and and tying your
hands behind your back
it's just crazy you know it's very true
and I was thinking when you were
described yourself as a liberal I found
that rookie is a wrong word but I used
to describe myself as a liberal and I
just don't feel comfortable describing
myself as a liberal anymore because
people I now associate as being an
inverted commas liberal to me behave in
the most a liberal fashion possible if
you noticed that the people who would on
the left who would use to have used the
word liberal don't use it very much
anymore hmm
progressive aggressive yes took over
liberal and and I think that's apt I
think it's telling I think it's apt
after all the word progressive is
fundamentally meaningless it only made
its going forward and it's like I wrote
in a column at some point um you can go
forward into a pit what I find
interesting is the flip that has
happened because you keep talking about
young people even we're old enough to
remember when it was the right who
worsen Soros it was the religious right
who was saying you shouldn't talk about
sex on TV you shouldn't do this you
shouldn't do that you mustn't talk about
that the tip of laws of the world and
and now it's been completely flipped
yeah and I think that's one advantage to
being older I mean um I'm always looking
for them having lived through the 60s
and having experienced the all the
restriction coming from in the u.s. of
course it would be the Republicans I was
born at the tail under the McCarthy era
I wouldn't have lived through it but
there was still that residue I grew up
with a lot of anti-communist guff and
and it was still there were still all
these things you couldn't do like take
drugs and have sex and have fun and it
was of course the left that said we're
gonna do whatever we want and that you
know push pushed against all the
restrictions and you know fundamentally
changed culture to to be more genuinely
liberated where you could do more of
what you whatever you wanted
so that was my understanding of what it
meant to be on the left and it's true
it's completely flipped around and
[Music]
that's concerning primarily because I
don't think it's controversial to say
that the left controls the mainstream
media and whatever may be going on in
the White House still controls most
mainstream cultural institutions not to
mention the universities oh yes
certainly academia is absolutely
dominating so if all of those
institutions
view free speech as a right-wing issue
then we're in trouble because that means
that it is you know that they are
funding their institutionally hostile
did the concept of freedom of speech
I think the moment the the left and in
terms of you know using T V terminology
jump the shark as it were was when they
just became absolutely obsessive
identity politics and it's just to the
point where everybody has to have a
label now yeah we all need to label
every single person you would this I am
this different because you have this
label it means this and it's such a it's
it's retrograde and what I don't
understand is why it's not pointed out
more often that it's sexist and racist P
we're fundamentally being told that what
is most important about us are these
categories into which we were born and
didn't have any choice in right
oh nobody asked me if I wanted to be
white and and this is more important
than anything else about us it's anti
individual but it's also it is it's
racist and sexist it's it's uh it's
saying that whenever I meet anyone the
most important thing that I'm supposed
to note about them is the color of their
skin their gender and their sexual
preference and maybe whether or not
they're disabled but these are this is
that defines that person for me that's
that and that's going to govern how I
deal with them well I thought that's
what we were supposed to get away from I
grew up trying to get away from that
that we were supposed to be able to see
you know all these stereotypes we have
of each other is and our obsession with
these these categories into which we
fall are impediments to our ability to
have equal fair and personable relations
and we're not we they are keeping us
from being able to see each other as
individuals and the goal of the
the goal of these liberation movements
was to release us in to a world in which
we are a world of individuals where we
can actually see each other and interact
just as people the identity politics
movement is the antithesis of that
approach and to me it's just it's so
backwards and I I don't understand how
they get away with it I don't understand
why that's not more obvious well one of
the reasons is that anyone who says it
tends to get destroyed we had a friend
of ours who's a rapper black guy come on
the show and he said that you know the
idea of white privilege is a racist
concept he said that on the show and
good for him yeah and immediately he
started getting people call it calling
him all kinds of names trying to show
anyone who speaks out particularly if
they're from one of those communities
are gonna get slams and if you're a
straight white man and you say something
about how it's racist oh no here's
straight white man you're not supposed
to say the rest of the you've got 20
minutes to say whatever you want I think
it's a very important point because some
of the most horrendous ritual that I've
seen damed
you know black conservatives and I
wouldn't be enough they get racist abuse
hurled at them from their own community
it is racist with the terminology they
use yeah because they're their Uncle
Tom's they're their turncoats
yeah I actually there's the the the guy
who is writing in The Times The New York
Times uh how's that was it Americans
like um about this case at Harvard his
name is Randall Kennedy this is the
second piece of his that I wish I had
written and he's a he's black and he's
on the the faculty at Harvard and he's
really smart and he's very sensible
grounded perhaps liberally minded in the
old sense I'm a huge admirer but I bet
he gets all kinds of stick yeah
the terminology is interesting because
Toki I I'm like one of the things that
happens to us is we are a right-wing
podcast in inverted cup or really yeah
apparently oh gosh I wish you told me
even though Francis is left-wing I am
kind of 90s liberal as I like to call it
before Liberals went mental you know but
just automatically discussing some of
these issues concerns about identity
politics concerns about sensoria sness
automatically your right-wing you know
and that's why it's so difficult to have
these conversations because when you try
to do that you immediately get bracketed
into this little group that's evil and
it's very difficult to get out of well
part of the problem is these directional
terminologies what their connotations
are and there's a fundamental political
unfairness to the fact that when you say
left-wing it's neutral - good right and
if you say right-wing it's evil
and essentially what right-wing now
means it doesn't mean that you want a
small state don't think that a long time
ago and and you want to balance the
budget
it means racist yeah oh excuse me
it means white supremacist or I don't
know what the next one is and that's not
fair that's not fair it means what do
you I mean for example I am an economic
conservative but what what word do I get
what direction do I get socially it
sounds to me like you're very liberal
when you talk about the individual about
you know sex drugs rock and roll
whatever yeah yeah well I'm I am a
economic conservative and a social
liberal
and the best ideology I can pinpoint i
roughly call myself a libertarian the
problem with with that word in the u.s.
is that libertarians have a reputation
for being Kooks they all think that
you're obsessed with the gold standard
and there's no logical connection ya was
in the UK the problem with that word is
no one knows what it means yeah yeah I
know I've often got blank stares when
I've used it but I fundamentally reduces
to the core principle that you should be
able to do whatever you want as long as
you don't hurt other people yeah and uh
that sometimes been interpreted as
meaning that you can't have
environmental regulations which is
absurd because if you pollute the
environment then you hurt other people I
mean it I so I I prefer a state that has
a light touch
I probably support of flat tax as
ultimately the most just that kind of
thing in turn in directional terms um I
think of myself as perpendicular to the
left-right axis so and where we are now
because I think we're quite a
challenging moment but I do see it as
being a slight tipping point where
people on the Left has started to become
more aware that their own side in all
the tears oh how can I put this a
technical term I've gone batshit can you
do you think this is gonna get better or
do you think we need to is going to get
far worse before more people start to
wake up I don't know I mean I'm glad to
hear you say that and I'm not sure I
share that view my sense is that there
is a splitting off of older classically
liberal people who are concerned about
what has happened
the hard left and you know the the
publisher of Harper's Magazine for whom
I have started writing a good example
Rick McArthur I mean he's you know I
dyed them all Democrat probably roughly
my age maybe a year or two older and but
can't stand what's happening on campuses
can't stand all this hysteria and and
and restriction and there are a lot of
people like that mark Lila is another
one but again more my generation I do
not see it happening as much among
earlier generations and that's why I
find people who like Ella Whelan and
Brendan Brendan sorry
we're so encouraging just because of not
only are they incredibly articulate but
they're younger and and I hope they have
a lot of friends I hope they have a lot
of supporters their own age but I I
don't mean enough of them and we often
and because you're so brilliant with
words and summing up what words mean I
hear the term work bandied around a lot
and I can never win what my mom goes
from frenzy what is walk and I don't
know how to it how would you explain
work culture and what the word work
means in where we are now walkers from
my perspective it means self-satisfied
self-righteous and certain of your own
virtue what's interesting to me about
that word and I've been watching it is
it
co-opted by the critics of the whoa
curry because it sounds kind of stupid
and therefore it's very and it's it's
monosyllabic right we're really tired of
the the vocabulary that has
traditionally been used to denounce the
hard left
you know the snowflake metaphor and the
the term virtue signaling I think it's
done pretty heavy lifting and it's now
worn out woke is perfect and we've just
taken it and like I've noticed it's all
over the spectator and it's it's it's
being used to make fun of the people who
made up the word and I hear it less and
less from the people who to whom it
describes okay so like we've stolen
that's a really good point actually
very accurate and you now have this
thing with companies trying to do all
these stupid ads where they did Gillette
no and there's this phrase now go walk
go Brook which is a really tightly
captured thing of what often happens to
businesses when they dive too deep into
this wormhole of intersectionality so
but use a good example of it having been
it's something like reclaiming but it
it's in that you never claimed to do to
begin with it's it's because it's just
claiming it's just just capturing this
from the enemy if you like if there is
such a thing I've forgotten what I was
going to ask actually but I think with
with this whole work thing and the way
you talked about generations as well is
it sounds to me like you're not
particularly optimistic about how things
might be going forward in terms of
pushing back against this the extremes
of this ideology my sense is that
something has to run its course and I
guess it's I mean I keep waiting and
it's not over
and I wouldn't be surprised if something
happens something probably big and bad
because that is usually what it means
when something happens if it makes all
this silly obsession with with language
and and and identity seem irrelevant and
beside the point
and dated in other words you know
there's a war there's a there's a
natural Cataclysm there's a something
terrible happens and and then the then
it's just all that stuff is over because
this is definitely first world problem
stuff right it's people who are just
don't have enough to do don't have
enough real problems what I'm offended
well I mean I guess that applies to me
as well you know in some ways the but
one of the things I'm most despair of
about the identity politics movement and
what in general what is happening on the
on the left is that in refuting it I
spend my time and therefore the
increasing amount of my precious finite
life battling ideas that that I
shouldn't have to battle the fact that I
ended I have ended up spending hour upon
hour writing or talking about a concept
like cultural appropriation means that
in some ways the left has one that is
they have they have managed to colonize
my life with their stupid idea
even sang cultural appropriation pains
me and it's one of those concepts that
knocked out of the park in five minutes
and it's still hanging around and when
people get you to spend your time and
your intellectual energy even on
refuting this stuff they have succeeded
because they have controlled the
conversation and I'd rather be having a
different conversation so in some ways
I'm very health conscious about how much
I've ended up writing about the the
constellation of issues that has
sprouted up around identity politics
because I I feel as if they have
contaminated and infested my mind and
I'll be dead soon and that's what I did
and I there's a way in which it's
important to to fight these battles but
I think it's also important to keep them
keep a sense of proportion because our
time is valuable
it's an frustration for us as well
because you know we've had
world-renowned evolutionary
psychologists on the show and instead of
talking to them about genuinely
fascinating things about human evolution
human history human behavior we spent 40
minutes talking about the basic
differences between men and women
because those things are now in question
mm-hmm you know and we have to have a
world-renowned scientist explain to us
that men and women evolved to do
different things and therefore their
brains are slightly different therefore
you might see certain differences
instead of talking about something
that's actually interesting I think
ironically a comedian some of this up
the better guess we've had on the show
Andrew thought he said talking about
difference between men and women used to
be hack comedy which only the worst
comedians did now is cutting-edge
groundbreakers believe someone's telling
these truth bombs it's just ridiculous
so I totally take your point and thank
you for giving us an hour
we wasted it together that was a
pleasant party
listen Lionel thank you so much for
coming on tell us
our last question always is what do you
think is the one thing that we're not
talking about and this made Tyson - what
we just talked about what's the one
thing we're not talking about that we
should be talking about population
that's Mike that's been my pet subject
since I was 16 years old and it still
was and I was right and it is the most
important issue in the world it was when
I went when I was 16 it is even more so
now and all this talk about we're all
obsessed with the climate change issue
nobody talks about where it's coming
from
it's it isn't just you know the West and
its cars it is also what's going on in
India and China much more than what's
happening in Britain for example and
it's it's caused by people and the the
UN originally predicted that we were
going to level off at around 9 billion
well that's out the window and now it's
at least ten point three
it could go considerably higher what's
happening in Africa is not going
according to plan
they're supposed to be having much much
smaller families than than they are and
that's going to pose a real issue for
for Europe because I don't you know it's
now predicted that Africa will have over
4 billion people at the turn of this
century that's a very inhospitable
climate not just because of climate
change it always has been inhospitable
it's mostly desert it has problems huge
problems with with water with with with
supporting life and then you add to that
that there's a long history there of
poor governance there there's a there's
a very good reason why a lot of people
want to leave that continent and
especially if four billion people end up
being present at the same time they're
not gonna stay there this data and it's
it's going to that's going to be the
issue of the century how the West deals
with the migratory pressures especially
from Africa and secondarily from the
Middle East and I don't have any easy
answers but in terms of what we don't
talk about that's what we don't talk
about it but by the way Thomas Friedman
columnist in the you know Times writes
lots of books agrees with me Oh Linus
have a thank you so much for coming on
the show it's been a pleasure as always
follow us on all the social media by
Lionel's books of course I imagine that
you are not on any social media itself I
am NOT I kind of had that intuition that
you wouldn't be but follow us on social
media that makes this even more special
as always and if you're a big fan of the
show do support us through patreon you
can send us money through PayPal as well
so that we can keep the show going thank
you very much for tuning in and we will
see you in a week from now and you've
forgotten it again what have you
forgotten oh my show yes yes come to see
all well that ends well in Edinburgh for
the whole of August I'll be doing my
debut show about freedom of speech as
you will know yeah it's gonna be great
isn't it France it is it's gonna be very
very good it's at the gilded balloon at
7:00 p.m. okay I forgot that as well you
know so on this publicist now go and see
it it's going to be great you should be
able to buy on the infringe website or
the gilded balloon website if you want
to come and see me I'm at the angel
comedy club Bill Murray in August so
come and see me and be able to find it
on the website if I haven't been
cancelled by them by offending
but in American people all right thank
you very much not happening no it's not
happening yeah I will be erased from
memory but probably well they would
agree of it anyway
okay guys but you've been thank you very
much for listening watching please
remember to leave iTunes review all the
rest of it and we will see you next week
[Music]
there is the form that you were asked to
I said by signing this contract this is
the unicef on campus SOAs right it was
asked to sign an agreement that his
routine would not contain racism sexism
classism ageism ableism homophobia
biphobia transphobia xenophobia
Islamophobia anti religion nante atheism
I think it doesn't quite complicated
mental arithmetic to offset the fact
that people didn't know funny
you have absolutely no sense of humor
you feel like you're just I mean you're
just so fing a Bevin out right you know
alright now that we got there in the end
you did a good thing by people that are
teeth needed right as I know I've got an
itch one of them is I haven't got any
racist sexist homophobic jokes I have
been a student at the University where
you can't make any joke about anything
if these poor little local students get
upset with drinking get over yourselves
it's not about comedy it's about
ordinary people up and down the country
and here in Britain and in America
feeling like they can't say what they
think I really got I get it I get it
especially especially the women who want
to become a member when Gareth Bale
right when from Tottenham to Real Madrid
the guy left a perfectly good club for
more money everybody feels like we're
we're all kind of under arrest we're all
everything we say can and will be used
against us in the court of public
opinion and they're coming for the
comedian's first because we're we're the
ones that is you say are allowed to
transgress but everybody else feels it
and that's why the stories got the
restless though it has
[Music]